me
初めまして私はに入った喉と申します
喉はアイヌ語で花という意味があるんですけれどもよく素敵だね可愛らしい名前だねと
いう風に言っていただきますしかし私のお母さんはアスファルトを搗きあがった生えて
くるお花のようにたくましく強く生きるのよという風に言われながら育ってきました
今日は意識のバリアを取り方
洗うコツという事で一つ提案していきたいとおもいます
皆さんは私を見てまずどんな印象を受けましたか
まず車椅子に乗ってるなっていうふうに気づきましたよね
その他にはどんな印象を受けたでしょうか
例えば見た目で子麻生優しそう
身体の強そ弱そうというふうにそれぞれ見た目で大善星を決めると思うんですけれども
実際にお話をしてみると全然違う衣装だったなっていうふうな経験がみなさんもあると
思います
私は小学校の時にですね
スキー学習というものに参加したんですけれども
スノーボードに座る前の椅子を取り付けた
なんちゃってスキーというものに乗ってスキンえんそくにみんなと一緒に参加しました
私は小学校の3年生から車いすマラソンに参加しているんですけれども
今乗っているこの車いすとをなぜものでショートレースの3キロに初めて参加しました
そのときに実は黄色の車椅子に乗ったおばあちゃんがいたんです
私は当時おばあちゃんにまさか巻いる理由はないだろうというふうに思いながら
スタートしたんですが残念ながら負けてしまいました
私はとっても悔しかったです
でもその悔しさをバネにたくさんたくさん練習を積み重ねた結果
翌年にそのおばあちゃんを追い越して何と優勝することができました
ありがとうございます
me
ショートレースで3キロから始めた私が5キロへと進みその後に中学校からですね
本格的に競技用の車いすのレーサーというものにも乗りました
実際に見て目はうとわかると思うんですけれども前のめりになって前景をして車いすを
こいれるマラソンというものを続けています
さてそんな私なんですけれども
実は根っからのスポーツウーマンですね
ただ車いすに乗っている姿を見ただけだと想像しにくいのではないでしょうか
そんな私に実は転機が訪れたのが2015年の12月になります
皆さんはノルディックスキーという競技をご存知でしょうか
メディアに取り上げられていることも多いので知っているという方もいらっしゃると
思います
私はその12月に初めて朝日岳という場所で強化合宿に参加させていただきました
それをきっかけに売るディッグスキーを始めたのですがもうそのノルディックスキーと
いう競技が虜になってしまいました
普段は雪がバリアに感じているんですけれどもやっぱり車椅子ではなくシットスキーと
いうものに乗った瞬間に自由に動くことができたんです
とても楽しかったです
そんなシットスキーはアルペンスキーというスキーのスキーたがあると思うんです
けれどもそれよりの細いものを使っています
これは私が書いてる絵なのでちょっと見にくいかもしれないんですけれども
そのスキー板の上に座るための椅子を取り付けたシットスキーというもので協議をして
います
私のように車いすに乗っている選手もいるんですけれども
え
そのクラス分けは剤というクラスになります
その他にも足を切断した選手も同じように剤というクラスにいます
そんな中ですね本当にたくさんの今までお世話になった方々のおかげで2018年の
ピョンチャンパラリンピックに筋をすることができました
私は山をですね冬の雪山を登って下る
かなり高低差があるんですけれどもそのノルディックスキーという競技で
21またその取るディックスキーに射撃の様子を加えたエアライフルで遠くの的を打つ
んですけれどもその競技では13位と
いう結果でした
これは宮の沢の射撃場で練習をしている様子になるんですけれども
このように銃を構えてですねまずその場所に行ったら
横に倒れるんですね
倒れた後に射撃で打ってまた起き上がってということをしてまた
すべています
そんな私がですねちょっと昔話をしたいと思うのですが
私が中学校の頃
堺のグループ学習の時に一人の女の子に言われたことがあります
私あなたが車椅子だから嫌いって言われたんですね
とってもビックリしました
ですが陰口をコソコソ言われるよりも直接言ってもらえてよかったなというふうに思っ
ています
私がその後になんで嫌いなのっていうふうに聞くと分からないと答えました
あなたに対して普通に接したらいいのかそれとも何か手伝った方がいいのかそれが
分からないという風に言われたんですね
そのように私とその子の間には少し壁があったんだようです
その他にも例えばなんですけれども皆さんが電車に普段乗っているときに
人の顔色を伺って席を譲ろうかどうか悩んだりする方もいるのではないでしょうか
これも一種の意識のバリアと言えると思います
例えば皆さんがバスに乗るということをまず何もやり方が知らないとします
そんな時に周りの人の行動を見てようやく切符を入れるんだなっていうふうにわかって
行動すると思うんですけれども
これって時間のロスになりますよね
実際にすぐに教えてくださいと周りの人に聞けばわかると思います
ですがそれがなかなか難しいですね
やって欲しいこと助けてくださいって言うことと実際はやってほしくないっていうこと
その2点をきちんと相手に伝えられるようなそんな風に気が何話あるような社会になっ
ていくと素晴らしいなというふうに思いました
そんな中で絶対にやられたら困ることっていうのがあります
やってほしくないことには実は種類があると気づきました
そんなやってほしくないこと絶対に困ることというのは具体的に言うと急に後ろから車
椅子を押されることです
これをされると実はこの車いすのタイヤと
泥除けカバーが付いているんですけれどもそこの間に指を子をガッと挟んでしまうん
ですね
なのでかなりそれが痛いんですかーべリッターがれちゃうんですよ
なのであのそれをなくすために一言ですね
あの
お手伝いましょうかという風に言って頂けるととても安心します
その他に自分でやるべきことこれは
やるべきことだからやられたら嫌なことというものがあります
具体的にお話をすると私はいえが山の坂道の中にあるんですけれども
だいたい人通りがないんですね
そして私は美術を習っている学生なんですけれども
絵画で絵を描くときの大きなキャンバスをこの背中にはさめて歩くことが多いです
だいたい大きさが本当に私の座高より大きこーんなに大きいものになるんですけれども
それをたまたま通った人が見るとすごく大変そうだなというふうに見えるんだと思い
ます
大丈夫ですかお手伝いしましょうかと言っていただけるのは本当にありがたいんです
けれどもまあ当然もう一回人が通るわけじゃないので自分でいかなければなりません
そんなときに大丈夫ですとたはいうとああああせっかく声をかけたのにこっちちょっと
生意気だなって思われたらすごく嫌だなって思うんです
なので一言ありがとうございますと珍島相手に感謝の気持ちを伝えるようにしています
意識のバリアを取り払い自分の意見をきちんと言える
そういったことがとても大切なことだと思います
お互いの勘違いをなくすためにもきちんと断るときにはありがとうというふうに伝える
ということが大切だと思います
そんなことあることに対しても寛容的な車載になっていけると素晴らしいと思うので
周りの人ももちろん私自身ももっともっと行動を起こして変えていきたいと考えてい
ます
私は
学校の美術の教員になるのが夢なんですけれども意識のバリアを取り払って
また自分の意見をきちんと相手に伝えられ
周りの環境をじーっと目を配っていけるようなそんな人たちを育てていきたいなという
ふうに考えています
単純なことかもしれませんがありがとうと相手に伝えるということとまた
大丈夫かなぁ声をかけてみようかなというふうに積極的に声がけをして去って行くと
もっともっと良い世界になっていくのではないかと思いました
ご静聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]